Oh
welcome all these basics birthday bash
so so all these basics apparently turned
one year old released the Bulls oh yeah
they released an updated version of the
game and I wasn't exactly gonna look
into it too deeply except they said that
there's a new ending as a thank you for
play in the game and giving it so much
love
I don't know how get that ending but I'm
guessing I have to beat the game again I
don't think I have to beat it with all
the answers wrong cuz that was really
hard so I'm gonna try to beat it with
the first two notebooks correct cuz uh
well if you do one way then he's way too
fast for you to get but I think it's
easier to beat if you just do the first
two right yeah I think it'll be fine
like I I remember a load I hate you
Baldy I hate your guts I hate you just
as much as I remember I hated you god
it's loud in here oh god the sensitivity
is still just as high as it was before
that's good can I leave can we go on
that field trip can you not kill me oh
that's that's quick is right yeah yeah
buddy here I'm doing great okay
[Music]
Wow WD no squeeze I don't know what that
means but I guess it means no door to
squeeze uh I hate everything I don't
want to do this oh god here we go
uh huh got it oh okay here we go
god dammit why am I doing this I hope I
don't have to beat it on hardmode to bid
it for the good oh god I remember which
way I used to go to get the optimal just
now oh god why is the sensitivity so
high okay oh god this is to be the mouse
yeah how do I look like this not like
this no no no buddy I know you do I know
you do buddy I know you do yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah hey there's a gift in
here Hey look at that
hey hey buddy you got a lot closer than
I thought it was good what the [ __ ] he's
so fast what is what is this what is
this talk halt wait am i here where am i
I don't know remember anything hello
[Music]
no thank you I don't like anything about
was that you are a saint
you're a saint you're a saint you're a
saint yeah I like you now you're okay
right there's no reason I need to go in
here so what I need to do is I need to I
need to get I need to get familiarised
again with where everything is in this
game because I don't remember I don't
remember
none
that's okay all right you're okay for
now I don't like you but you know you're
okay for right now it sure is great
that's right if you get all of them
wrong you get so unbelievably angry okay
so I'm gonna go I think I recall there
being another one in here and there's
two on the far hallway so it's listening
this and Busan okay one zero blah okay
okay just don't bring him over to me
that's all I ask of you I'm gonna try to
use this squee door thing we worked I
think I think it was silent was that
silent I don't know if it was silent
okay I think I'm gonna beat this first
try wink wink wink wink wink wink wink
definitely gonna happen totally dead
totes totes definitely gonna happen holy
[ __ ] that's the big birthday cake okay
big old boots what does that mean what I
didn't do nothing a corridor okay good
well I should have used the no squee on
that I need rest
oh wait a minute no the boots wear the
boots good oh [ __ ] he's too close oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's too close oh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh wait I've goofed it
I've goofed everything I've goofed my
life oh wait I should have used to
squeeze the no squeeze okay yeah he's
definitely gonna catch up to me at this
rate yeah catching up to me at this
juncture is a definite yes well if I get
caught by anything I'm so screwed you
know what I'm gonna just do one of these
moves and then no no no no
no I won't marry oh no I won't marry you
no I won't oddly enough you know
surprisingly I still won't marry you
after all these years
hello what is this what is it slowness
what is this slowness oh yeah this is
good this is good thing this is what we
call it good no no no no I mean okay
yeah yeah okay okay so this isn't the
worst thing in the world it's not the
best thing in the world but I'm gonna go
around here I'm gonna lock the door and
then gonna make a big ol well okay so I
remember how to play now the thing that
I need is I basically just need
everything to beat the game at that last
door IRA I remember now I remember I
remember now let's just beat this
because I can and I will
I can and I will in order to beat the
dues those goons to get what eyes needs
maybe senses you know detention for your
face yeah alright yeah ok ok all right
god I thought I'd been rid of those
smacks the smacks that haunt my dreams I
don't know if I can make this one
probably can't but here we go alright
don't don't don't don't
alright it's fine everything's fine
everything's fine I'm gonna try to go in
here again maybe I won't get caught this
time time sound like a distraction or
something
that baby food so if I can just get
around a corner I can lose oh I can lose
him he won't hear me so what I do is I
go down silent hallways I just like wait
he's gonna lose me no no no no no no no
okay he's far away now he lost me so I
can go oh hey I oh I forgot there was a
door here [ __ ] if I go around he won't
hear it until I open the other door okay
this is this is all good it's all good
all good
oh please don't be down this hallway
where is he where's the smacks oh no he
spotted me bald a dowel alright fine
we'll do this differently huh no we
won't do it differently I'm gonna bide
my time and wait for the right
opportunity cuz that's how I do know nah
my opportunity no no wait I just had an
idea
despite her poor eyesight does that mean
what I think it means that there's a
chance
well I'm bones it's not gonna get me it
got me
okay why am I doing this to myself no no
no no no no no okay alright good good
good yeah yeah yeah that's what I
thought it's what I thought no let's not
play let's not play let's not play what
if I I haven't moved I can't move what
that doesn't make any sense what
happened
I'm not sure I know no please please
I'll give you squeeze oh God
I've completely forgotten all my
instincts have gone out the window oh no
Baldy no no bulging no not like this
okay so it's it's fairly easy to lose
him on this segment here
I thought I used the squee Oh door type
okay maybe it doesn't work on the yellow
doors or something no don't take my
candy no you won't
oh no no no balls no balls no balls you
won't I've got some ideas I've got some
real clever real smart ideas formulating
up in this brain up here that's not part
of my idea I'm gonna no squeeze this
door
oh yeah oh that's a good no squeak now
it doesn't even know I'm in here except
for that math on the bat to be wrong I
don't know what big old boots do I'm not
a hundred percent sure what Oh goodbye
thank you sweeper man you're a real hero
oh no no no oh oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god I have an idea a big brain idea
all right everybody
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna he
doesn't go in roads right and close the
door let the door close and he won't
know I'm in here he does not know I'm in
here it didn't squeak it did not squeak
no squeak so now he doesn't know where I
am
I'm not here no mo yeah this big brain
time and then I hit this one then the
next one and then bought up bing bada
boom it's all good still don't know what
big old boots do but uh here we go he
has no heat last thing he heard was in
here no no no
[Music]
he doesn't technically know I'm here
right where is he oh [ __ ] oh he knows
okay he knows guys Red Alert he knows as
it turns out surprisingly he knows
didn't think it was so but it turns out
he knows um
well well this is a problem um well okay
oh no no no no not like this no not like
this what are you sweeping where you
sweeping where you sweeping - hey what a
big old boots - I don't know I don't
know there you put them on then you take
them off I don't know if they're like
make you go faster if they just make you
a little [ __ ] not that whoa where you
going which way you going yes okay I'm
gonna go in here grab this whatever is
in here I love it I want it I need it
give me that no sweet love it okay love
it let's see ah dess t-bar I think we do
better Oh baldie anti hearing and
disorienting tape that's perfect
whatever that means
oh wait I know what that means uh ice
stupid oh come on
[Music]
apparently if you go around a corner and
oh [ __ ] well that's not good but
you stop apparently no yeah parently
yeah Wow that's pretty impressive
the alarm clock do again Oh Frick that's
big
what does that do I have no idea what
that did I have no idea what happened
but Baldy doesn't know I'm here but I
also don't have any of the other items
that I would like to have before the end
okay whatever let's let's just do this
fine let's see if we can sprint to the
finish okay so I'm gonna do what I
usually do I have a yellow door lock I'm
gonna go into the I'm gonna go in here
no don't play okay so he's gonna he's
gonna come up behind me oh no not like
that no why would you do that no not
like that
no no I said behind me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no no no not today I might be
able to duck in this room here ice weed
it so
he doesn't see this oh he saw that he
saw that okay she thought she saw that -
I gotta get around this corner good not
here okay well I wanted to be Boyer I go
boink alright that's the best we're
gonna get I don't think it's gonna be
enough to get away from him for the rest
of the game but you know you know you do
what you can you do what you can and if
you can't do it then you don't do it no
you suck so much you suck so much god oh
[Music]
hi alright well that was a new discovery
there's a little corner that you can
hide in and prevent your death but
that's about it I I have no idea why I'm
still doing this alright so I'm gonna
cut ahead and get to the point where I
know I've got a generally good good
handle on this [ __ ] these are
interesting items but okay I have no
idea what big all boats do I just don't
know I have an idea I really don't know
what that does I think I got this I
think I got this what I got to do oh
[ __ ] not that way
oh good bye okay
oh no no no what the [ __ ] no oh no god
[ __ ] damn it are you kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me oh god damn
you damn you alright okay alright we're
gonna do this another way oh [ __ ] okay
please don't put me in detention please
don't put me and Diane Chen this is fine
you know why because I've got the smarts
I got the smarts he doesn't have the
smarts see like you see what I got you
know what I got I got the smarts boom
see now even if I [ __ ] no wait no I did
that wrong he's gonna hear this oh [ __ ]
I did that wrong okay yeah I I did that
wrong [ __ ]
well now I'm boned so if I can make it
to the nut the other door but I mean I
did that completely wrong I should have
used the squeak I have an idea
there's no way in hell it's gonna work
but I have an idea
okay he definitely heard that why is
this wait no oh [ __ ] okay the doors get
unlocked I and the doors get unscrewed
that makes sense that that makes sense I
get that okay I get that that's fair
that's fair that makes sense I was going
back for the other door because I
thought it got it was squeezed and
therefore was safe but I was wrong okay
there's no way he knows I'm in here
right that's how that works
yeah that's how that works he has no
idea nope not a clue
what I know no oh no no no no no no no
no [ __ ] why what what why why oh that's
not good
[ __ ] okay so I'm in good pretty good
shape I just need the last one this
store is squeezed now I just got to
remember I've got two good items I got
the safety scissors and the soda so this
should be the one as long as I soda
correctly which is a question here we go
this is gonna be the one this is it I
think so basically what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna aim up very carefully aim cool
okay that should get him all the way
then it should just be a leisurely
stroll right am i right people are this
should be it I think yeah
ship it here we go
whoa go on throw out the candle blow out
the candle Wow okay
oh I'll blow it I'll blow it's so good
oh you guys shouldn't have whoa
it's a dream come true three two one a
poof of food ah
hello um oh oh oh hello oh okay um right
I'm gonna go down this hallway that I
didn't notice was here cuz I couldn't
look up home all DS office okay alright
what is that is that a janitor or
something okay ah oh I don't want to
touch none of you why sir no book okay
before I go there let me just I just
want to see what all is in here before I
go jumping end up any kind of
conclusions here I just want to explore
hi oh hi oh all right you know I don't
think I wanna touch ya I don't think I
want to touch those things at all even a
little bit
I think touching them would be very bad
right okay what's down here am I free to
run with reckless abandon gimme more
cookies those are the first words I ever
said and you know what I never got any
cookies yeah okay all right Oh
[Music]
oh okay re they're just nothing it does
nothing when you have the will don't say
never just leave those thoughts th OTS
thoughts hey okay okay so let's touch
this notebook cuz at least it seems to
be away from me I know we didn't go into
baldies office but frankly the original
ending was baldies office so I'm trying
to see if there's something else
no books says I got eight of eight I
guess I'll go get the other one then
there I just don't want to touch him is
the thing I I just I really don't want
to touch him oh whoa whoa you know no
what no what huh I let it out I
shouldn't have let it out
oh I let it out okay okay goodbye um
night oh this is a tight squeeze if ever
there was one
okay hey buddy hey how you doing excuse
me nine of nine all right well let's go
the only door I haven't explored is
baldies office oh okay so I've got the
two notebooks it was talking about nine
I don't understand what it is referring
to it's something change out here no
whoa so there must be some kind of
another door or something around here I
guess I didn't go into this one wait
where does that door lead wait there's
another ah but be on to something
where does this door lead huh what are
you hiding ah yeah what were you hiding
from me oh oh no count the balloons how
many of each color can you find go do it
oh I don't know oh these are balloons
wait and I gotta write this down and
here we got two purples and a green and
another blue out here blue blue purple
purple blue okay purple blue I think I'm
being methodical about this now I have
no I
how many balloons were in the bottom but
I don't think it's asking that I think
it's just asking about balloons up here
okay all right
one orange two Purple's three Purple's
there's one in the back there
three Purple's one blue one green one
orange I don't think you count as a
balloon
let's go go ahead and say that right now
I don't think you count as a balloon so
I think I got them okay so we've got
five six seven blues we add six green we
add three and this we had one did I get
it
did I do it does that mean there's
something that I'm missing all right let
me let me recount again because my
system was real [ __ ] oh did I miss
that guy just seven happy seven I think
I was right for everything except purple
I lost one purple there are eight
Purple's okay now I know okay let's see
if this does anything oh wow yeah that
was it okay whoa you are smart I am I am
smart whoa whoa wait wait wait wait wait
wait what whoa whoa what do I do about
that what do I do about that whoa
no wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
whoa I don't like those balloons
well those balloons aren't those aren't
good balloons whoa whoa whoa what the
freaking fresh hell is right
oh hi okay you're fine I think ooh oh
that's not good then go through walls
kind of I guess whoa whoa what is that
wait there's something else here what is
this what is that oh [ __ ] that's not a
good sign
I don't like the sign of that oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa
I can't run oh oh [ __ ] I'm out of run oh
hey hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
whoa ah oh yeah yeah oh yeah oh well
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's like the
worst bullet-hell ever I don't know
I don't know what to do about this boom
pow pow holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
well okay well alright mildly
uncomfortable whoa ah wahoo okay I guess
that's it okay goodbye okay wow that was
a thing so that was a lot of work for
that creepy which is what ball these
basics is all about I suppose so that's
great happy birthday dove all these
basics one year out I don't know if
anything new is happening in the ball
these basics world but you know I guess
when the next thing comes out I'll go
find it so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to check out
the other ball these basic stuff I've
done I'll put in the description below
and yeah I don't know when that full
game that they're making is gonna come
out but it's got to be eventually so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]